ja und wie angekündigt jetzt die Rede
des csu-parteivorsitzenden Markus Söder
zum politischen Aschermittwoch in Passau
diesen Gruß würde in Berlin niemand
machen aber wir machen ihn wir sagen
ganz bewusst grüß Gott hier zu allen in
der Halle grüß Gott zu allen Zuschauern
in Bayern und der ganzen Welt liebe
Freundinnen Freunde wir sind wieder da
hier in Passau
[Musik]
wie habe ich das wie habe ich euch
vermisst
wir sind wieder hier in unserem Revier
liebe Freunde das ist das Wohnzimmer der
CSU und für jeden Parteivorsitzenden ist
es die größte Aufgabe des Jahres mit
seiner Partei und vielen Bürgerinnen
hier zusammenzukommen es stimmt schon
die anderen versuchen seit Jahren
Passau nachzumachen bei den Grünen
sitzen weniger Gäste als bei uns Ordner
sind und auch die anderen liebe Freunde
wollen so sein wie wir aber das schafft
keiner wir sind die stärksten wer sind
die besten wir sind in Wasser
das schöne ist für mich ich muss heute
nicht nur als Ministerpräsident sondern
ich darf als Parteivorsitzender reden
und da ist Klartexter bei anderen gibt
es Klamauk bei anderen gibt es Chichi
bei uns gibt es rhetorisch deftige
Hausmannskost und man kann es so sagen
die Politiker Korrektness hat endlich
Pause weil wir am Ende hier in Passau
das sagen was wir denken und Frauen das
zu sagen was die Menschen fühlen wir
haben keine Schere im Kopf sondern wir
sprechen aus Herz und Leidenschaft das
ist pass auf pur liebe Freunde
und dieses Jahr passt der Aschermittwoch
perfekt der Countdown läuft am 8 Oktober
ist landtags- und bezirkstagswahl das
wird ein Marathon mit
volldampflebefohlenen Freunde die
Ausgangslage ist besser als 20 18 und
viel besser als nach der Bundestagswahl
sind wir bitte ehrlich nach der
Bundestagswahl 2021 da waren wir schon
in einer Delle in einer Depression und
die Opposition klopfte sich auf die
Schenkel und hatte Hoffnungen heute zu
Beginn des Jahres 2023 ist es genau
andersrum die csus dem Aufwärtstrend und
die Opposition die verunsichert die
Umfragen sind wieder stabil die Tendenz
geht nach oben wir sind wieder nah bei
den Menschen wir sind wieder nah bei den
Leuten wir sind in der Mitte von Bayern
wir haben uns nach einem harten Jahr
wieder nach oben gekämpft wir sind vorne
wir sind gekommen um zu bleiben wir
wollen die Landtagswahlen im Herbst
gewinnen liebe Freunde und zwar zusammen
und es war kein leichter Weg
denn es findet alles unter
außergewöhnlichen und das schweren
Bedingungen statt Pandemie Ukraine
wir sind jetzt im Jahr zwei der
ampelzeitrechnung
das erste Jahr war an das darf man
wirklich sagen ohne jemand zu nahe zu
treten chaotisch es ist kein Vorwurf
wenn man schwere Entscheidungen zu
treffen hat aber wenn man falsche macht
muss man das Benennen das ampelprinzip
ist seit über einem Jahr spät
entscheiden hin und her entscheiden
handwerkliche Fehler machen und sich
dabei zerstreiten ich glaube man kann
sagen die neue Bundesregierung die Ampel
ist die schlechteste Bundesregierung die
Deutschland je hatte Liebe frei Freunde
das peinlichste ampelkapitel Kapitel war
bislang das Thema Verteidigungspolitik
wir hatten so große Hoffnung Liebe
Alexander Dobrindt nach der Rede des
Bundeskanzlers und es war bislang nicht
so groß Enttäuschung
alle reden von Zeiten Wände aber es ist
bislang nur eine Zeitlupe
viele Ankündigungen und die Wahrheit das
einzige was bislang wirklich zustande
gekommen ist waren 5000 Helme liebe
Freundinnen Freunde sonst nichts nichts
bestellt nichts gekauft nichts gemacht
mittlerweile werden von den 100
Milliarden er Großteil durch die
Inflation aufgefressen und kann gar
nichts gehen und der Grund war eine
spd-ministerin die länger am Amt lebte
als manche am Boden liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde ja
diese Ministerin Frau Lamprecht den
Namen müssen sich nicht mehr merken
aber diese Ministerin war eine Blamage
für Deutschland es war ein Fehler vom
Bundeskanzler so lang an ihr
festzuhalten und das einzig gute an Frau
Lambrecht ist dass sie endlich weg ist
liebe Freunde und Freunde das einzige
wir wünschen übrigens den neuen
Verteidigungsminister alles alles Gute
und wir unterstützen auch die Politik
gerade weiß ich der Jahrestag näher der
Ukraine zu helfen wir stehen zur Ukraine
und wir wollen auch das Russland diesen
Krieg nicht gewinnt sondern dass die
Ukraine erfolgreich ist und ich sage
auch danke weil ich den amerikanischen
generalkonsor sehe es ist einfach wieder
ein gutes Gefühl wenn wir Amerika
Deutschland und besonders Amerika und
Bayern wieder zusammenstehen danke für
eure Engagement wir sind da gemeinsam
aber wisst ihr
wir helfen wir helfen auch mit Waffen
aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl dass
ein Teil in dieser Ampel im Moment
völlig überdreht und zwar die Grünen
früher waren sie Ostern jetzt sind sie
militärmarschieren
wenn die Grünen früher früher von Leos
und Leoparden geredet haben dann redeten
sie meist vom Artenschutz liebe Freunde
jetzt jetzt hat man den Eindruck die
Grünen reden sich gerade zu in einen
kriegsrausch besonders Frau bärbock sie
sagte vor einem der wichtigsten gremen
Mann für das es gibt in Europa den
Europarat Deutschlands Achtung
Deutschlands sei im Krieg mit Russland
ich will mal eines sagen
vielleicht darf man den Passau des ein
oder andere überzeichnen was wir in der
Regel nicht tun ja
wir sind sehr sanft und empathisch hier
ich sehe das an den Gesichtern
aber eine Außenministerin muss aufpassen
was sie sagt die Eskalation von Sprache
kann schnell zur Eskalation von Gewalt
führen und deswegen will ich sagen wir
helfen in der Ukraine aber Deutschland
ist nicht im Krieg mit Russland das kann
nicht gehen herr Scholz stoppen sie
endlich Frau bärburg mit ihren
unbedachten Äußerungen zum Schaden
unseres Landes
ich bin freundlich zu ihr aber ich muss
sie fragen was soll eigentlich diese
feministische Außenpolitik Liebe
das wirkt wie ein riesiger Irrweg
man hat den Eindruck es wird nicht
Diplomatie Betrieben im Außenministerium
sondern Mission das bisherige Ergebnis
war dass man Kreuze entfernt
Seele umbenennt und statt kundige
Diplomaten mittlerweile NGO Aktivisten
in die Regierung holt wir entwickeln uns
unsere Ampel zur eine ngo-republik und
die Außenpolitik der Grünen ist eine
neuer grüner Wilhelminismus nach dem
Motto am grünen Wesen soll die Welt
genießen eines sage ich euch schon so
werden wir auf Dauer zum einsamen Mann
oder wie Frau bärbock sagen würde zur
einsamen Frau in Europa wir wollen das
nicht die Grünen sind ein
Sicherheitsrisiko für unser Land liebe
Freunde
wir stehen zur Hilfe
Bayern ist ein herzliches Land wir
helfen wir helfen gerne wir haben mehr
Menschen aus der Ukraine aufgenommen als
beispielsweise Frankreich ich danke
unseren Kommunalpolitikern lieber
Landrat Kneidinger und vielen anderen
herzlich dafür für die Aufnahme für
alles was getan wird um zu helfen
aber wir spüren gerade dass das alles an
seine Grenzen stößt an die Grenzen der
Machbarkeit ich danke den Kommunen noch
einmal aber wenn selbst grüne Landräte
in Bayern was zum Glück nur eingibt ja
zum Glück ja wenn der sagt wir bräuchten
mal ein bisschen Zeit zum Durchschnaufen
aber übrigens gleich von seinen eigenen
grünen wieder zum Rücktritt aufgefordert
die alten Reflexe funktionieren noch
fakt ist unsere Hilfe steht vor der
Herausforderung fakt ist der Zugang in
diesem Jahr lieber Joachim letzten Jahr
war stärker als
2015/2016 und deswegen sagen wir an der
Ampel auch die adressiert sie muss
Aufwachen es ist nicht davor von
Menschen die Schutz suchen sie ist in
der Vorwurf einer Bundesregierung die
das ganze katastrophal organisiert liebe
Freunde und Freunde sie können es
einfach nicht und wenn sie dann einen
Gipfel machen und Kommunalvertreter
einladen und außer einen kalten Kaffee
und eine Brezel ist nichts gibt dann ist
das einfach zu wenig wir erwarten vom
Bund dass er zwei Dinge tot auf der
einen Seite sage ich klar wir stehen zu
Hilfe wir stehen zum Migration für
Arbeit aber wir sagen nein zur
Überforderung der Kommunen und Nein zu
illegaler Zuwanderung Deutschland liebe
Freunde und Freunde
und Frau Feser den Name ich immer
irgendwie sympathisch finde weil als
altersfan erinnern mich das immer an
Phaser
aber
Frau Feser muss nicht nur Wahlkampf in
Hessen machen
sondern sie muss für Deutschland ein Amt
ausfüllen wenn sie jetzt nicht bald
Vorschläge macht Joachim wie der Zugang
gesteuert und die Kommunen entlastet und
mehr Geld an der Stelle überwiesen wird
wir geben übrigens als bayerischer
Freistaat geben den Kommunen große
Unterstützung ganz bewusst wenn sie das
nicht so drauf Frau Feser dann wird sie
die nächste Frau Lamprecht in Kabinett
von Scholz und es würde auch den Kanzler
gut anstehen wenn er sich endlich selber
um diese Probleme in Deutschland kümmert
und nicht nur durch die weltreist liebe
Freunde wir haben hier die Probleme und
eine Regierung muss hier agieren und
musste die Menschen da sein
weil ich jetzt schon wieder weiß dass
der einer nicht Journalist die
Augenbrauen zuckt
wir sagen ja zu Integration
wir sagen ja zu Unterstützung aber wir
sagen nein auch zu einer Änderung des
ideologischen Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
liebe Freunde habt ihr das mitbekommen
die neue Regierung will das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht komplett
verändern
das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft ist die
höchste Anerkennung eines Staates
ist nicht wie die Mitgliedschaft in
einem Verein oder einer Yoga-Gruppe ja
wer die Staatsbürgerschaft will braucht
ein Bekenntnis zum Land ein Bekenntnis
zu den Werten und auch ein Bekenntnis
zur Sprache die neue Ampel will die
Sprache quasi völlig ausschalten ich
sage ich aber eines wir wollen keinen
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht leid wir wollen
einen wirkliche Anerkennung der
Staatsbürgerschaft und um die zu
bekommen muss man die Sprache sprechen
wer Deutscher werden will muss auch
Deutsch sprechen können liebe Freunde
und Freunde alles andere ist doch ein
Unsinn
und so nebenbei
wenn alle von Integration reden kann ich
nur empfehlen
keine Seminaren Berlin zu besuchen
sondern eine Reise nach Bayern zu machen
wir sind ein Vorbild für Integration
Liebe Joachim wir haben im letzten Jahr
mehr Zuzug als Nordrhein-Westfalen
dabei haben wir trotz des hohen sozuges
die niedrigste Kriminalitätsrate die
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote und das
zeigt bei uns in Bayern klappt
Integrationen das liebe Freunde ist der
fundamentale Unterschied zwischen Bayern
und den linken andere reden von
Integration wir machen sie Bayern ist
der deutsche Meister der Integration und
deswegen brauchen wir keine altbackenen
linken Multikulti Belehrungen mehr wir
machen es auf unsere Weise und die
anderen sollen sich ein Vorbild an
Bayern nehmen liebe Freunde
Landwirtschaft erfolgreich für
Deutschland
das ist übrigens kein ampelbashing
im Wesentlichen
das ist nur Sorge
Sorge um Deutschland und natürlich um
unser Land Bayern
ein weiteres sorgenpunkt waren ist das
Thema Energie
seit einem Jahr ging es hin und her erst
dieses Bayern bekommen überhaupt kein
Gas wir haben gekämpft und es ist
gekommen dann hieß es hier innen sich
noch habe die gasumlage soll kommen was
die Preise erhöht hätte wir haben
demonstriert sie viel dann hieß es eine
gaspreisbremse Alex kommt aber nur für
ein Monat wir haben kritisiert es ist
die ganze Zeit und bis heute ist es ein
Theater weil nicht genau geklärt ist ob
auch für Ölheizungen eine entsprechende
Unterstützung gibt da will ich nur eines
dazu sagen
in den Städten gibt es weniger Ölheizung
aber eine Bundesregierung oder eine
Mehrheit im Parlament die Ölheizungen
schlechter behandelt als Gas zeigt nur
eines sie haben kein Verständnis von den
ländlichen Räumen wir fordern Gleichheit
nicht nur der Gaskunde braucht den
lastung sondern auch der deine Ölheizung
hat und Pellets benutzt liebe Freunde
was an der Energiepolitik der Ampel
nervt
ist auch hier wieder zu spät halbherzig
und auch Ideologie
am Anfang fand ich das noch alles ganz
witzig
Frage woran erkennt man grüne
an ihren wasch Gewohnheiten liebe
Freunde
da habe ich
gerne kalt tolle Idee im Winter der von
mir hochgeschätzte Winfried Kretschmann
hab mir während einer
ministerpräsidentkonferenz wir sitzen
nebeneinander mögen uns wirklich mit
seinem Waschlappen erklärt wo an welchen
Stellen man
ich kämpfe bis heute jede Nacht darum
die Bilder aus dem Kopf zu bekommen
und eine der super
Senatorin in der grünen aus Berlin sagte
waschen Salbe völlig beschäftigt das
könnte man sein lassen
stellt euch mal vor wir hätten uns seit
November nicht mehr gewaschen liebe
Freunde ja das wäre dann hier ein
besonderes Aroma und wenn wir aufstehen
kleben wir die Bänke mit
ein Quatsch nach dem anderen aber da
könnte man doch lachen wie wir es tun
aber schlimmer ist diese
durchdränkung mit Ideologie beim Thema
Kernkraft
die Entscheidungen zu kennen die in
Deutschland sind ohne Logik und Verstand
gemacht liebe Freunde ohne Logik und
Verstand
was für ein absurd ist Theater nur wegen
den Grünen
die Grünen faseln vom Klima und Baggern
aber lieber nach Kohle
lützerathisch sage ich euch jetzt voraus
wird das Wackersdorf das emotionale
Wackersdorf der Grünen wird
es ist doch sowas von unglaubwürdig und
peinlich in Deutschland Frankreich
bietet könntet ihr uns ein bisschen
Atomstrom geben wir wollen ihn nicht
ist es nicht peinlich und lächerlich
wenn man andere Länder wie die USA aber
Holland bitte Norwegen könnten wir uns
ein bisschen von eurem Gas geben wir
trauen uns nicht selber zu Wort und wird
sehr liebe Freunde und Freunde dann
tatsächlich zu einer totalen
Tag nach Katar fährt vor der WM und
großspurig erklärt wie die Kataris sich
zu verändern haben hat er uns super
Effekt bei unserer Mannschaft gehabt ja
und am nächsten Tag
ist der war alles sehr sehr alt und am
nächsten Tag liebe Freunde und Freunde
am nächsten Tag
am nächsten Tag fährt man hin macht
einen hofmix und bettelt bei den
gleichen die man am Tag zuvor beleidigt
hat um Gas so gibt Deutschland in der
Welt ein peinliches Bild ab und daran
sind die Grünen Schuld liebe Freunde
Robert Habeck ist ein netter Mann
so ein bisschen knuffig und knuddelig
rüber ja bei denen ins Feld und wirkt
das so ein bisschen wie der Captain Iglo
von der Küste
aber eins sage ich euch
wenn wir ehrlich sind ein
Wirtschaftsminister der sich schwer tut
zu erkennen dass das auf die Aufgabe von
Produktion nicht zu einer Insolvenz
führen könnte den kann ich nur eines
sagen das ist das schlechteste
Wirtschaftsminister alle Zeiten Ludwig
Erhard würde in Grab rotieren wenn er
wüsste dass er einen solchen Nachfolger
hat tut mir leid
wir schimpfen aber nicht nur
wir haben einen eigenen Plan entwickelt
welche wir haben einen eigenen Plan
entwickelt für die Krise und zwar
verlässlich von Anfang an eine Linien
entwickelt wir haben härtefallfonds
gemacht fast zwei Milliarden lieber
Albert für alle Bereiche der Wirtschaft
der Bürger sozialen Einrichtungen
Sportkultur Vereine und wir setzen auch
sehr auf den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien weil wir dann noch besser
werden
da kam plötzlich aber letztes Jahr so
Mitte des Jahres eine schlimme
Befürchtung auf also das gelesen habe
die Grünen behauptet Bayern sei Bayern
neuer bahnenergien ganz am Schlusslicht
völlig verunsichert ab den Wirtschafts-
und Energieminister Hubert albacher
eingestellt Obst
[Applaus]
und es ist schon ein Hammer liebe
Freunde und ein Meister Beispiel für
politische Unwahrheit
ich würde meine eingehen lassen in
Bayern bei den Erneuerbaren wirklich
total schlecht wäre dann wird man sagen
müssen wir halt nur besser werden aber
im letzten Jahr der Generalsekretär hat
es sehr schöner mehr aufgedröselt und
die Landesgruppe und der alexander dobin
hat das Bundestag eine Anfrage gestellt
und eine Antwort bekommen danach sind
wir da klar vorne wir sind bei der
Dynamik und beim Ausbau erneuerbaren
Energien im letzten Jahr absolute Spitze
25% des deutschen Ausbaus sind in Bayern
gemacht worden mehr als
Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Baden-Württemberg zusammen wie man dann
ständig behaupten kann dass der dann der
Spitze steht da Abstiegskandidat war
kann kein Zufall sein und ich bezichtige
hier Meiniger Grünen die es immer wieder
behaupten schlichtweg der Lüge und ich
kann nur eines sagen wer in der
Regierung lügt hat keinen Anspruch
länger Regierungsmitglied zu sein liebe
Freunde es ist gang und gäbe
und obwohl wir gut liegen legen wir zu
weil ihr müssen mehr tun wir müssen noch
unabhängige von Russland werden Manfred
natürlich
und wir haben übrigens auch einen
Zuwachs nach Bayern so brauchen wir
Energie deswegen haben wir noch eine
extra halbe Milliarde freigeschaufelt
für erneuerbare energieprogramme
Photovoltaik das sind wir übrigens
stärker dass sie das mal gehört haben
stärker als Nordrhein-Westfalen
Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz
zusammen
übrigens für die künftige Metrologie
Wind nimmt in Deutschland ab habe ich
gelesen Sonne zu bei Wasserkraft
erzeugen wir mehr erneuerbare Energien
als Rheinland-Pfalz und ja liebe
Freundin beim Vince sind wir nicht ganz
vorne aber vor Baden-Württemberg
interessant deswegen weil wenn selbst
grüne Regierungen beim Wind im Süden
nicht ganz so erfolgreich sind könnte
theoretisch könnte es vielleicht auch
damit zusammenhängen dass im Norden mehr
Wind weht und im Süden mehr die Sonne
ist man könnte es geografisch
zusammenfassen im Süden Scheins und im
Norden pfeift liebevollen feiern was die
Realität
aber wir machen da mehr
Michaela im Staatswald vielen anderen
Bereichen wir haben jetzt bereits
aufgrund der veränderten reforming
Christian fast 25% neuer Anträge aber
wisst ihr was jetzt schon wieder losgeht
dein entscheiden uns wir wollen es
machen aber es gibt eine Gruppe die
wieder überall dagegen das sind übrigens
nicht wild gewordene CSU-Bürgermeister
dieses Wort behindern es sind meistens
NGOs und leider auch einige
Umweltverbände die gegen alles und
überall klagen jetzt muss ich mal ganz
ehrlich sagen ein Teil unseres
Fortschritts wird behindert weil Leute
die nicht mal Anwohner sind gegen
bestimmte Dinge klagen können es ist
echt mal an der Zeit diese Verbandsklage
Rechte irgendwelcher
ngo-funktionäre einzuschränken liebe
Freunde bis nach Vorankommen in
Deutschland könne da stehen bleiben
also wir sind bei Photovoltaik super bei
Wasser super bei Geothermie wir bauen
beim Wind aus und wir sind noch in einer
anderen Disziplin sensationell und jetzt
kommt ihr gleichzeitig ein Vorwurf
es betrifft das Thema Biomasse
im letzten Jahr war ein Drittel des
Zubaus aus Bayern wir haben mehr
Bioenergie aus Biomasse als ganz Hessen
ein riesiges Land
erneuerbare Energien hat
komischerweise es ist die Frage
komischerweise setzt die Bundesregierung
nur auf Wind sie behindern Wasser und
sie behindert Biomasse und warum wohl
weil sie zum einen den Süden nicht mag
und zum anderen die Landwirtschaft nicht
achtet liebe Freundin kann nur eines
sagen
vor einigen Wochen war die Grüne Woche
in Berlin seine Leistungsschau der land-
und Ernährungswirtschaft was
sensationell Bayern hat sich super
präsentiert alles sind zu uns gekommen
dieser logisch wir haben das beste Essen
der Welt liebe Freunde ja das beste
Essen der Welt
also Grüne Woche ist auch toll das
einzige was mir eine Grünen Woche stört
ist der Name
aber sonst super der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Herr ötzte
mir macht dann auch das ist positiv eine
ernährungskonferenz lädt alle
Landwirtschaftsminister der Welt ein um
zu sagen wie stoppen wir den Hunger der
Welt und eine zentrale Forderung ist
dass die starken westlichen Länder die
Industrieländer mehr Nahrungsmittel
produzieren so weit so gut Frage
produzieren wir in unserem Land alles
was wir können müssen wir eines sagen
wir haben in Deutschland ein solches
Management was Flächen betrifft dass wir
uns stilllegen von den Grünen die
oberste Direktive ist ja liebe Freunde
haben wir einen zeigenwende oder nicht
wollen wir der Welt helfen ihre
Ernährungsprobleme zu lösen oder nicht
und wenn wir das wollen dann hört
endlich auf in Berlin Flächen
stillzulegen Flächen zu blockieren lass
die Landwirtschaft ihren Job machen die
können das am besten besser als grüne
Ideologen liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
sie wollen flächenspiel legen Michaela
und die Tierhaltung komplett reduzieren
50%
. man spürt eine richtige Fleisch und
wurstphobie Liebe von
übrigens wir essen auch alle ganz Salat
wir essen auch gern Gemüse eine mehrere
weniger so
ich finde es auch völlig in Ordnung wenn
sich jemand vegetarisch und vegan
ernährt jeder soll es entscheiden aber
wenn ich höre dass in Münchner Kitas
entschieden wird weder Fleisch noch
Fisch da muss ehrlich sagen was tut man
den Kindern an stellt euch vor ein
Kindergeburtstag soll mit Brokkoli und
Karotten zum Erfolg geführt werden eine
völlig absurde Idee
[Applaus]
und einige haben sogar Hass auf Fleisch
richtigen Hass die
Tierschutzorganisation Peter da gibt
sicherlich ein paar ganz tolle Leute
kennen zwar keine aber gibt's
die sagen wer Fleisch ist
dem soll dein
fortpflanzungsverbot auferlegt werden
wisst ihr was ich das Absurde dabei
finde außer dass ich so viel Kinder habe
also wir können
es wird über Hormone im Fleisch
debattiert
könnten zu viel harmonisch sein
aber gleichzeitig will eine grüne
Ministerin Kindern Hormone verabreichen
um ihr geschlechtlich zu entwickeln
liebe Freunde die absurd ist es
eigentlich in unserem Land mittlerweile
gewonnen ist dann immer normal
und
das Besondere ist dabei man hat ja schon
einen Satz Essen gefunden jetzt heißt es
kein Fleisch aber Insekten
damit Kabinett diskutiert das heißt
jetzt noble food immer Niederbayern
Erwin Huber sagt ja die hausgrille und
der
getreideschimmelkäfer sollen jetzt
essbar sein
es ist schon Wahnsinn ja vor drei Jahren
hieß es rettet die Bienen und jetzt
futtert die Käfer liebe Freunde oder ist
schon lustig oder
also
ich will es hier und wenn ihr damit
einverstanden habt als offizielle
Botschaft auch der bayerischen
Staatsregierung der CSU zusammenfassen
liebe Freunde wir essen wieder
Schweinsbraten statt Insekten oder Maden
Müsli und wenn ihr das wollt Liebe grüne
dann könnte das Zeug selber fressen wir
machen das nicht niemals
ich will ein Bekenntnis abgeben für
unsere Landwirtschaft für unsere Bauern
Liebe Günter Felsner heidelein
vorgängersitz mit da wir stehen dazu und
seid bitte ehrlich ihr habt uns auch oft
geschimpft und
vielleicht auch ab und zu ein bisschen
zu Recht denn immer aber es zeigt mal
ehrlich die FDP ist doch in der
Regierung eine totale Enttäuschung die
Freien Wähler reden viel aber tun sich
schwer was umzusetzen die AFD sinnlos
und die Grünen echte ideologische Feind
die einzigen auf die ihr euch wirklich
verlassen können und zwar nicht nur mit
Sonntagsreden sondern praktischen Arbeit
ist die CSU nicht verspreche euch wir
arbeiten daran einen neuen Park mit der
Landwirtschaft zu machen denn wir wollen
nicht die Norddeutschen Agrarfabriken
wir wollen unseren Erhalt der feierlich
feierlichen Betriebe liebe liebe
Familienbetrieb als ein agraraktie
und wenn ich schon beim Landwirtschaft
bin kürzer Einschub zum ländlichen Raum
bis heute
glauben die ampelparteien auch in Bayern
die kleine SPD
die noch kleinere FDP und vor allem die
Grünen glauben dass der ländliche Raum
liebe Freunde eigentlich eher so eine
Art
Naturschutzgebiet eher so eine Art
Museum ist sie haben nicht verstanden
dass der ländliche Raum die Seele
Bayerns ist wir werden diese Seele
erhalten liebe Freunde und Freunde für
uns ist der ländliche Raum zukunftsraum
und nicht nur urlaubsausfahrt für einige
müde Großstädter liebe Freunde wir
stehen dazu
deswegen
christian hat es gesagt
auch der ÖPNV ist ganz besonders wichtig
bis zu einer landkreispräsident
kamasien der Nachfolger schönes Leben
im Präsidentenstuhl das
wir setzen im Haushalt Albert Bürger hat
sich erreichen lassen wir setzen im
Haushalt so hoch wie nie den ÖPNV an
Baden-Württemberg übrigens nimmt
Maßnahmen zurück ne wir setzen drauf
klimapusse ein Ticket 49 und 29 Euro
Schienenverbindung Radwege Rad gesetzt
aber jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt
es tun wir alles
aber wir sind nicht gegen das Auto Liebe
Freunde wir sind nicht gegen das Auto
man kann im ländlichen Raum ohne das
Auto auch schwer seine Mobilität
erhalten übrigens echte autofeinde sind
die Grünen was wir für ein Theater jedes
Jahr haben mit der IAA Internationalen
Automobilausstellung München man spürt
geradezu die Abneigung aber ich will es
hier mal deutlich machen wir stehen dazu
wir sagen ja zum Straßenbau wir sagen ja
zur Ansiedlung von BMW-Werk wir sagen ja
zum synthetischen Verbrenner und uns
fällt aus dass die FDP in fünf überhaupt
nichts durchsetzt wir sind das kann man
sagen und bleiben es auch Bayern ist
Autoland und die CSU bleibt die einzige
echte autoparteil Liebe Freunde und dazu
stehen auch wir brauchen es auch davon
hängt unser Wohlstand ab
für mich hat ich weiß andere war wegen
unsicher
was sagt der Markus wieder wenn ein Baum
umarmt ja
aber lieber als den Grünen liebe Freunde
für uns hat Klimaschutz den absoluten
Top Stellenwert
mit dem die sich dafür ankleben
normalerweise zu den klimaklebern nur
ein kurzes Kapitel
normaler es geht bei uns das als leben
und leben lassen deswegen würde ich
sagen mai kleben und leben lassen
wenn man meint ja
wir finden schon Fleck irgendwann
Parkplatz oder so wegen mir ja bei
schlechten Wetter ganz besonders gern
aber nicht und das sage ich ausdrücklich
wenn es um den Schutz von Eigentum und
von öffentlicher Sicherheit geht
liebevollen Freunde das sind wir
konsequent jeder der gegen bestehende
Regeln verstößt muss mit der Konsequenz
des rechtsstaatsrechnen auch und ganz
besonders in Bayern liebe Freunde
es gibt jetzt den einen an der Seite
[Applaus]
mit dieser Ding und Bilder und so
das kann die alten Maler dafür ja aus
den Gulasch zu wenig schon
aber
sie haben doch einen ehrbares Motiv
sie sind doch Menschen die sich Sorgen
machen und konsequent leben wollen
sind wirklich alle klimakleber
konsequent moralisch
nicht stört immer nur wisst ihr jeder
kann sein Meinung haben wir will völlig
genommen aber wenn das ganze mit
doppelten Boden stattfindet da wird es
kritisch klimakleber
die in Urlaub fliegen irgendwo nach
Thailand und Bali liebe Freunde wer mehr
Interesse an Miles and More statt am
Klimaschutz hat hat kein Recht dir zu
leben mein Vorschlag ist fliegt doch
alle mal nach China klebt euch am Platz
des Himmlischen Friedensfest da hat er
mehr erreicht wenn Klimaschutz als in
Bayern den Verkehr aufzuhalten liebe
Freunde wir brauchen euch nicht wir
brauchen euch nicht
noch mal zu Energie weil man Anschluss
sind wir sind übrigens auch das Land des
nicht nur erneuerbare Energien ausbaut
wie kein zweites tatsächlich so
sondern wir sind auch das einzige Land
mit einer eigenen wasserstoffstrategie
Kraftwerke die wir bauen
Industrieprojekte Tankstellen wir müssen
auch Pipelines machen warum
weil es die Bundesregierung ablehnt im
Leistungssatz Deutschlands im Süden es
gilt für Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
eigene zu legen
wir wollen das von Norden entwickeln und
man spürt es übrigens aus jeder Faser
des ampelkörpers egal wie groß oder
kleiner sein mag man spürt es richtig
die Abneigung gegenüber den Süden sowie
Schröder einmal sagte ihr Bayern bekommt
nur Steine statt Brot machen die das
jetzt ganz genauso es gibt keinen
bayerische Ministerin oder Minister in
der Bundesregierung ich würde ja noch
verstehen wenn die Ampel sagt es gibt
keine qualifizierten grünen FDP oder
Sozis aus Bayern da gebe ich zu aber sie
machen es bewusst weil sie Bayern
benachteiligen wollen und das lassen wir
nicht so liebe Freunde niemals
und ein Beispiel
ein neues Beispiel
also Pipelines wollen sie nicht selbst
und dann kommt es aber her und sagen und
überhaupt
die Bayern müssen endlich höhere
Strompreise zahlen sei recht die
nordgrünen Feuer fordern und feiern sich
indem sie sagen die Bayern sollen
doppelt so Strompreise
die bayerischen Grünen Schweigen
übrigens dazu ganz interessant
Mensch zahlen wir wirklich so wenig sind
wir Empfänger in Deutschland
müssen die anderen sich anstrengend für
uns
nun ein kleiner Blick auf die Bilanz des
Länderfinanzausgleich lässt einen dieses
Argument doch leichter
ja
ich baue es erst auf
bis 1980 hat Bayern Geld bekommen
3,4 Milliarden Euro in der ganzen Zeit
danke
Zeit der Zeit haben wir über
108 Milliarden Euro bezahlt
wir zahlen jetzt mittlerweile 10
Milliarden pro Jahr 10 als wir die Klage
eingereicht haben was bei viererhalten
sollte eine Reform bringen auf den
Grundig hat es nichts gewirkt wir zahlen
60% des gesamten deutschen
länderfinanzausweis
Albert Bürger rechnet mir vor von 10
Milliarden könnten wir für 600.000
Kinder kostenlose Kita haben
für fast 400.000 Menschen Pflegeplätze
fast 150.000 Lehrern Lehrer anstellen
und wir könnten die zweite Stammstrecke
zweimal bauen und in jedem Waggon eine
Minibar einbauen dafür liebe Freunde
und
wer bekommt das Geld
Länder wie Berlin oder Bremen aus dem
Länderfinanzausgleich bekommen deinen
Bürger aus den beiden Stadtstaaten über
1000 Euro jährlich quasi umgerechnet das
länderfinanzen
jetzt erwarte ich ja nicht eigentlich
dass jedes Mal wenn Bayern nach Berlin
kommen eigentlich ein spontanes Demo
sein müsste oder man sich aus
Dankbarkeit dort vor die bayerische
Vertretung anklebt das könnt ihr sein ja
aber es ist schon absurd wenn man sich
das überlegt wenn man von dort an
oratschläge bekommt die Leisten sich in
Berlin Dinge die wir nicht können
dann wiederum leisten sich Dinge die mir
gar nicht wollen
und Sie bekommen dann dafür auch eine
Quittung bei der Wahl und ich finde es
schon ziemlich hart nach der
Bundestagswahl hieß es wer die meisten
Stimmen bekommen hat muss regieren und
es sei unmoralisch wenn der
Zweitplatzierte in Anspruch erhebt und
jetzt trifft sich die gleiche linke
Kartell wieder und es Wahlergebnis zu
ignorieren ich kann nur eines sagen Frau
giffeis sollte endlich und letztmals
ihre Stuhl räumen und das Ergebnis
demokratisch akzeptieren liebe Freunde
sowas Skandal
und wenn wir schon geben dann dürfen wir
auch ein Vergleich anstellen
so Sicherheit zum Beispiel lieber
Joachim großer Erfolg im letzten Jahr
seit 44 Jahren die niedrigste
Kriminalitätsrate in Berlin ist übrigens
dreimal
woran liegt es die Silvesternacht war
kein Einzelfall seine lange Serie von
Ereignis zum einen liegt daran dass wir
mehr Polizei haben ja und alles was wir
Polizei machen einschließlich
Grenzpolizei und Reiterstaffel war ein
Erfolg wir bezahlen unsere Polizei
besser wir geben in eine bessere
Ausrüstung aber das wichtigste ist wir
stehen zu der Polizei und genau da ist
der Unterschied zu Berlin in Bayern gibt
es keine rechtsfreien Räume in Berlin
werden Polizistinnen Polizisten
angehalten wegzuschauen liebe Freunde
die müssen sich dort mehr ums schendern
statt um Gauner kümmern wer die was es
denken statt gebe zu fangen Berlin
sollte die Hauptstadt der deutschen sein
sie ist die Hauptstadt der Chaoten da
gehört endlich aufgeräumt und zwar
schnell und rasch und konzentriert
und sorry
wir geben gern aber irgendwann ich kann
nur eines sagen für so etwas und vor
allem wenn diese neue linke Regierung
bleibt geben wir kein Geld denn
bayerisches Geld ist besser in Bayern
aufgehoben als in Berlin und darum
klagen wir gegen diesen unfairen
Länderfinanzausgleich liebe Freunde der
muss endlich geändert werden
die Ampel ist
die schlechteste aber vor allem die
teuerste Regierung aller Zeiten
Hunderte von Milliarden Schulden
dass ein FDP-Minister der vorderwahl
behauptet wir FDP wir machen zwei Dinge
nie
Schulden und steuern
dass der jetzt über vier fast 500
Milliarden Schulden macht ist schon
beeindruckt
er entwickelt sich zum Schulden Christi
von Deutschland Schulden Christian und
dann macht er auch noch so Tricksereien
er nennt seine Schulden Vermögen
ja er nennt seine Schulden Vermögen
Journalisten ja nach Christian Lindner
ist der der die meisten Schulden macht
da reichste Mann liebe Freunde
der letzte der das behauptet hat können
erinnern bei der griechisch
kommunistische Finanzminister
dass die griechischen Kommunisten
irgendwann Blutsbrüder der FDP werden
hätte ich auch nicht gedacht liebe
Freunde
unseriös hochziehen
Bayern ist das Gegenmodell wir halten
die Schuldenbremse ohne Trick sein wir
haben gleichzeitig höchste
Investitionsquote und warum weil wir für
die nächste Generation Liebe ju wollen
dass ihr stark bleiben könnt Edmund
Stoiber hat den ausgeglichenen Haushalt
eingeführt und wir bleiben seinem Erbe
treu liebe Freunde wir halten den
Haushalt ohne Schulden und es bleibt
auch so
und wenn wir schon bei der FDP sind
eine weitere Enttäuschung gerade wird
gerade Gerät Übersteuern
keine Steuererhöhung
aber sie haben die Steuern schon erhöht
die Erbschaftssteuer etlich haben
gemerkt vor Weihnachten Notartermin zu
bekommen weil ich so einfach ja
klammheimlich hat Christian Lindner die
Erbschaftssteuer massiv erhöht ohne
Freibeträge anzupassen
dass die FDP die Erbschaftssteuer erhöht
hätte ich niemals vermutlich gehalten
das ist ein Stück von Wahlbetrug
liebevollen Freunde und die FDP
Brandenburg hatte mal in einem
Landtagswahlkampf folgendes Motto keine
Sau braucht die FDP ich sage euch wenn
diese selber sagen wollen wir in Bayern
nicht widersprechen liebe Freunde
diese neue Steuer ist unfair weil es
keine Erhöhung der Freibeträge nach zehn
Jahren gibt sie ist ungerecht bei
regionale Unterschiede nicht
berücksichtigt werden in Deutschland
haben wir unterschiedliche Preise in
Bayern ist am teuersten
Ilse bei dir am Tegernsee der Grund auf
dem man Dixi Klo steht ist teurer als
manches Wohnhaus in anderen Teilen
Deutschland die wir vorhin Freunde
und deswegen können sich Bayern nicht
mehr leisten dass Eigentum das Häuschen
dass sie von ihren Eltern vererbt
bekommen haben zu behalten sie müssen es
verkaufen und Spekulanten aus anderen
Teilen der Welt kaufen ganze Landstriche
in Bayern auf liebe Freunde das kann
nicht sein das ist der ausverkaufte
Heimat durch diese Erbschaftssteuer der
FDP die muss weg die Erbschaftssteuer
die muss verändert werden und dagegen
wir
wisst ihr was ich an der Amt des so
beeindruckend finde eins schon
sie ist ja relativ ziellos bei zentralen
Fragen der Politik aber sie ist total
zielstrebig beim Umbau der Gesellschaft
man spürt richtig wie sie da sich gut
verstehen sie wollen ein anderes Land
ein anderes Deutschland zum Beispiel bei
Drogen
wie absurd ist es eigentlich lange an
der Maske im Zug festzuhalten aber die
Droge auf der Straße gut zu finden
lieber Klaus holitschek alle warnen
Ärzte Polizei die Europäische Union
Manfred warens holländischen Freunde
sagen tut nicht den gleichen Fehler
machen ich sage auch wenn der einen an
der glaubt da könnte man die Sitzungen
Gemeinderat deutlich entspannter
stattfinden ja
ich will für Bayern keine Drogen auf der
Straße und keinen Zugang für unsere
Kinder liebe Freunde Nein zu den Drogen
ich bin auch echt enttäuscht von dem
Mann Lauterbach ja
als Lichtgestalt gestartet zur Dauer
Nervensäge mutiert wenn man sieht denkt
man immer an Catweazle liebe Freundinnen
Freunde
und war der letzte der noch in der
Corona Schleife war aber das hätte ich
noch gesagt mein Gott was soll's ist
vorbei aber lieber Klaus dass er jetzt
eine Vorschlag macht für die
krankenhausreform die für unzählige
Krankenhäuser im ländlichen Raum das
Ausbringen würden das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren wir sagen hände weg von
unseren Krankenhäusern im ländlichen
Raum wir lassen uns die Gesundheit in
Bayern nicht durch ein Lauterbach kaputt
machen liebe Freunde
diese Ampel
die will ein anderes Deutschland eine
andere Gesellschaft das Leitmotiv heißt
woknis
und känzel culture nicht Wok Alexander
das ist es wenn Berlin Gemüse und
walkenes
es droht tatsächlich eine düstere
wokwolke unseren weißblauen Himmel zu
verdunkeln
diese walkness Idee haben es Befreiung
gedacht ist doch aber nichts anderes als
zu illiberalen Spießer zu montiert mit
wilden umerziehungsphantasien im
Mittelpunkt steht Sprache und Kultur die
Grüne fordern eine genderpflichten
Bayern liebe Freundinnen Freunde meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wir
bleiben bei der höflichen Anrede es darf
jeder reden was er will aber nicht
gender Pflicht in bayerischen Schulen
und Hochschulen lehnen wir ab ist mit
der CSU nicht zu machen
[Musik]
ist auch total abstrus ja wenn wir zu
unseren Schützen gehen dann Rede halten
da sind wir schon freundlich sagen die
beschützen Schwestern die beschützen
Brüder nein das muss gechändert schützen
brüderinnen heißt
das Schützenkönig muss genannt werden
die treffsicherste Person
eine Hexe ist nach diesen neuen Regeln
eine Zauberkraft inhabende Person
wusste gar nicht dass jede Hexe
Zauberkraft hat
der Spion des Spion heißt jetzt künftig
Auskunft schaffende Person
Familien werden verändert hat schon mal
erzählt Opa und Oma wird Zorn
die Muttermilch soll Eltern Milch werden
auch da wusste ich gar nicht dass das
geht ja
und Eltern werden künftig nicht mehr
Vater und Mutter heißen sondern
Elternteil 1 und Elternteil 2 und meine
Herren sie können sich vorstellen welche
Nummer wir nach grüner Vorstellung dabei
bekommen ja
die Kultur ist am stärksten betroffen
sie kennen alle Bully Herbig den
großartigen Regisseuren Kommandanten der
sagte letzte der Fernsehsendung er würde
sich nicht mehr trauen seinen Film der
Schuh des Manni zu machen
sofort dahinter gestellt einige Tränen
ein Freund Hubert Alba er steht dazu er
sei Winnetou
dann habe ich gesagt warum weil wir
nicht so ein schöner Mann sein
habe dir
die Verbindung
wir haben uns zusammengeschaltet wir
stehen so wie die Tour aber wir nicht so
ist ja nicht der erste und letzte
Angriff geht weiter
schneewittchen und die sieben Zwerge
soll künftig heißen schneewittchen und
die sieben Gefährten
wird sich weniger nach Märchen als nach
einem sehr leichten Film Mann liebe
Freunde
in Kraft vom Bäcker wird in
Baden-Württemberg abgemahnt weil er
Indianer auf seine Krapfen macht Jim
Knopf ich kenne alles stimmt noch Lukas
der Lokomotive der muss sich
wahrscheinlich ändern in München hat man
gesagt in München hat man gesagt man
darf wenn jemand ohne Ticket fährt nicht
mehr Schwarzfahren nennen es sei
schwierig ich frage mich wann man bei
uns anfängt zu sagen die CSU ist immer
die schwarze Partei sondern weil man nur
in Bayern sind wahrscheinlich die most
indigene Partei oder sonst schon sind ja
ein Unsinn nach dem anderen
oder mit Liedern mit Liedern Laila
da kriegen die Grünen Herzflimmern ja
Skandal im Sperrbezirk völlig undenkbar
oder unkorrekt sind Lieder wie Dschingis
Khan oder Manfred Moskau ja Moskau
und es geht bei Kinderliedern weiter und
ich sag's jetzt bewusst so dass mir
keinen Vorfall machen kann
die beiden Kinderlieder drei Punkt Punkt
Punkt mit dem Kontrast
oder Joachim noch schlimmer 10 kleine
ich bin sicher Claudia Roth schreibt im
Moment jeden einzelnen Text um liebe
Freundin ich kann ja nur sagen wir
wollen wirklich niemand verletzen und
wenn es gute Vorschläge gibt gerne aber
das ist doch nimmer normal das ist doch
völlig überdreht wir lassen uns von den
Grünen nicht Kultur und Sprache umziehen
nein nein nein
liebe Freunde
bei den Grünen sind ich habe sie heute
kaum erwähnt
die Grünen haben sich übrigens aber
wieder zurückentwickelt die sind wir
denn ideologisches Loch gebracht ja
völlig anderes Wertesystem nur einige
Forderungen der Grünen aus allen
Bundesländern die Grünen sind von
indianerverbot sie sind von
autowaschverbot sie von fleischverbot
Silvan böllerverbot sie sind sogar für
luftballonverbot liebe Freunde
grün heißt Verbot grün heißt nein nein
nein
die Grünen sind heute die größten
Spielverderber und Stimmungskiller der
Nation und auch wenn sie es möchte und
sich Anbietern wir machen kein
schwarz-grünen Bayern liebe Freunde wir
wollen die Grünen nicht in der
bayerische
wir sind
das gesellschaftliche Gegenmodell jeder
hat da klar die Linie nein steht für
Grün ja dafür steht die CSU wir bekennen
uns zu der liberale tastbar Ware bei uns
heißt das leben und leben lassen bei uns
heißt es was blaue Stadt Wok wir sind
keine ampelspießer sondern
freiheitsdenken wir Menschen bei uns
soll jeder nach seiner Fassung leben und
nicht nach der Grünen Pfeife tanzen wir
sind kein Zwangsstaat wir sind ein
Freistaat und dafür steht die Zehe so
und ich auch ganz persönlich dass wir
dafür kämpfen und das auch umsetzen
liebe Freunde
und ich frage euch
was ist denn eigentlich attraktiver
das Ampel Berlin oder das CSU Bayern
das können wir ja sein dass er eine
Abstimmung mit den Füßen geht wenn
übrigens alles immer so stimmt was
manche Medien über Bayern schreiben und
die Opposition so sagt dann müsste es ja
einen Exodus aus Bayern geben müsste
alle fliehen
kennt ihr Aufnahmelager gestrandeter
geflurte Bayern in Castrop-Rauxel oder
Wanne-Eickel
noch kein Kind
ist Gegenteil die kommen mir alle zu uns
man kann sagen man rennt uns fast die
Bude ein
einige suchen Schutz im wir gerne geben
aber die meisten suchen hier Glück liebe
Freunde
wir sind das glücksland
nicht jedes glücklich aber immer mehr
bei uns lebt man länger und waren es
lebt man besser in Bayern von zehn
Landkreisen mit der höchsten Kaufkraft
sind acht in Bayern und deswegen kann
ich nur eines sagen wenn man mal alle
Meinungen Kommentare weglässt und
einfach die Fakten anschaut die Bayern
Bilanz ist die beste in Deutschland und
es ist kein Zufall das hängt mit dem
Fleiß der Leute aber eben auch mit einer
guten Politik zusammen und wer macht die
gute Politik in Bayern
lasst uns die Fakten sehen und auch in
der Fragen war ja nicht stark weil wir
die stärkste Wirtschaft haben wir sind
absolut die Nummer eins in Deutschland
wir haben mehr Industriearbeitsplätze
als Nordrhein-Westfalen
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote wir haben
die meisten Dax-Unternehmen acht Länder
in Deutschland haben überhaupt kein
Dax-Unternehmen die Freunde unser
Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist größer als alle
Nordländer zusammen ist größer als das
von Tschechien Portugal und Griechenland
90 Prozent aller Nationen der Welt haben
ein kleineres Bruttoinlandsprodukt als
wir und jeder Feier vom Baby der geboren
ist bis zum ältesten Bürger
zusammengerechnet erwirtschaftet pro
Jahr einen Fünfer BMW liebe Freunde und
Freunde in anderen Ländern rechts zu
sehr kleine Autos aber in Bayern ist
einfach eine andere Liga und es muss
endlich einmal anerkennt und respektiert
werden
und Liebe Präsident der Handwerkskammer
wir haben auch die meisten Handwerk
25 Prozent aller Meister in Deutschland
kommen aus Bayern
und ich finde das Handwerk wird viel zu
wenig wertgeschätzt liebe Freunde ja
viel zu wenig wertgeschätzt
und deswegen haben wir uns bewusst
entschieden ein Signal zu setzen wir
setzen auf die Gleichheit von mastern
meistern wobei lieber Markus blumig mit
manchen Begriffen bis heute fremde Maß
der Bachelor immer ganz ehrlich ja wenn
man draußen irgendwo jemanden
fragteller sondern die meistens
aber egal wie man es nennt ihr versteht
was ich meine und deswegen bauen wir
Berufsbildungszentren aus deswegen
machen wir erstmals einen Tag des
Handwerks und als erstes und einziges
Bundesland nehmen wir die
Gleichwertigkeit der Ausbildung ernst
wenn das Studium kostenlos ist dann muss
es die meiste Ausbildung auch sein nur
bayern macht es leben Freunde sonst
niemand
also wir sind stark
wir sind aber auch sozial wir stehen in
unserem Namen mit drin wir sind die
christlich soziale Union
aber ist der Begriff der würde für mich
der Zentrale würde und wertschätzen
zwei Drittel der Bayern Glauben übrigens
dass es gerecht zugeht in Bayern
in Deutschland bei der gleichen Umfrage
Glauben zwei Drittel der Deutschen das
ist in Deutschland ungerecht sind
wir haben die niedrigste Armutsquote
Bremen hat eine 100% höhere Selbst NRW
50%
und wir kämpfen auch sehr für eine
gesunde den ländlichen Raum ich habe es
angesprochen lieber Klaus lieber Markus
mehr Studienplätze für Medizin Gerhard
wird auch Passau helfen mehr
Studienplätze für Medizin als NRW und
Niedersachsen zusammen
wir sind fast die einzigen die
Pflegeplätze fördert in der letzten
Periode über 4.000 in der nächsten und
festgelegt über 8.000 aber das ist für
mich ganz entscheidend
nicht nur Pflegeplätze fördern sondern
auch die Pflege daheim
wer sind die größte Gruppe der
Pflegekräfte in Bayern
sind die Angehörigen
70 Prozent werden zu Hause gepflegt
Partner die anderen der liebevoll
pflegen
Kindern die aufopferungsvolle ihre
Eltern betreuen und mittlerweile auch
Enkel die mithelfen dass ihre Großeltern
einen schönen Lebensabend und genau für
die haben mir liebe Freundinnen Freunde
ein Pflegegeld eingeführt von 1000 Euro
das war damals der Wunsch und das
wichtigste Anliegen und zwar leider und
ich sagte es leider
verstorbenen Barbara Stamm sie fehlt uns
allen mir auch
aber anstatt dass die Opposition damals
danke sagt nein nein alles heftig
kritisiert verschwendet das Geld
ich habe dann mal nachgeschaut ob das
stimmt aber Briefe gesehen habe mir eine
damals Niederbayern übrigens geschrieben
lieber mrwind danke danke für das Geld
wir sind davon von dem Geld zum Urlaub
an die Nordsee fahren
lacht sich naja Nordsee wenigstens nach
Fürth oder so wer ist bei uns bleiben
vielleicht passt es hier nicht her aber
vielleicht passt es gerade hier
pass auf was mit Leidenschaft und Liebe
zu tun
die Dame schrieb dass sie seit 40 Jahren
mit ihrem Mann verheiratet ist
und dass ihr Mann Demenz erkrankt
für mich übrigens ganz persönlich die
wohl schlimmste Form der Erkrankung die
es gibt dass man quasi aus dem hellen
Licht ins Halbdunkel geht nicht mehr
wissend
und für die Angehörigen einer der
schmerzhaftesten Erfahrungen der Pflege
wenn er geliebter Partner seine Eltern
eine Großeltern die ich nicht mehr
kennen
die Dame Schritt jedenfalls sie schrieb
wir sind dahin gefahren weil wir damals
unsere erste Hochzeitsreise gemacht
und sie hatte den Eindruck gehabt dass
ihr Mann
dass ihr Mann in den Momenten ein kurzer
Form der Wiedererkennung ist
aufwachensammeln erst sozusagen aus dem
Dämmerlicht des vergessen werdens
heraustrat und Erinnerungen hatte
ich kann es nicht beschreiben wie die
Frau ist lieber es hat mir damals es hat
mich sehr sehr gerührt
weil es ist ein Zeichen von Liebe und
Respekt denjenigen gegenüber den anderen
pflegt
und deswegen lasse ich es niemals zu
dass wenn Menschen einander in Liebe
zugetan sind pflegen helfen
aufopferungsvoll in der Partnerschaft
stehen das dann manche Politiker darüber
abfällige Bemerkungen machen wir sind
das einzige an erste Bundeslandes ein
Pflegegeld hat und wir lassen das auch
weiter so weil wir das wertschätzen dass
Menschen füreinander tun es muss nicht
alles der Staat Regeln sind wir dankbar
dass es die Familie gibt liebe Freunde
werde oft gefragt
wofür steht die teso
wenn man nachts geweckt wird möchten wir
sofort drei Dinge sagen
die meisten ich kennen wenn sie Nacht
bewegt dann sagen sehr interessante
Dinge ja
aber ich sage mal drei Dinge nur in der
Landespolitik von Sicherheit gar nicht
zu schweigen drei Dinge gibt es nur bei
uns wir sind das ersten einzige
Bundeslandes ein Pflegegeld hat
wir sind das erste und einzige
Bundeslandes ein Familiengeld hat Kinder
bekommen zur A bis zur Einstellung und
3000 Euro pro Jahr und wir werden als
ersten einzige Bundesland sein dass eine
kostenlose und kostenfreie
Meisterausbildung hatten jetzt sage ich
euch mal was wir sind doch drei ist
super Gründe die CSU zu wählen liebe
Freunde Vergleich zu den ganzen anderen
Parteien
also wir sind stark wir sind sozial sind
sicher
wir sind auf smart
wir sind Hipp und modern mehr als die
meisten denken die freuen Freunde
alle 20 bis 25 Jahre
die Erwin Hubert kommt Bayern an so
einen Sprungpunkt
er stellt sich die Frage die Welt
verändert sich gehen wir mit machen wir
was draus oder fallen wir wieder zurück
es war bei Strauss und doppelt so es war
bei Edmund Stoiber Sohn ist heute
genauso wir haben uns übrigens immer für
Modernisierungen entschieden wir haben
uns immer für die Zukunft entschieden
heute dreht sich die Welt schneller denn
je
Wissenschaft und Forschung sind die neue
Währung und genauso wie im Fußball in
der Premier League Geld Tore schießt ist
es bei Forschung und Wissenschaft auch
unsere Freunde die USA liebe sie ihr
verkauft uns nicht nur teures Gas gutes
Geschäft
dicke Freunde ja wenn die USA zeigt uns
wie es geht sie investieren in Forschung
und werben Wissenschaftler natürlich ab
und was ist die Antwort der Ampel darauf
sie kürzen den Forschungsetat das ist
ungefähr genauso eine Politik im Fußball
wenn man sagen würde
wir fahren zum schwersten Spieles
keiner ja
also Berlin kürzt und was macht Bayern
wir klotzen
liebe Freunde ich weiß ob das den
meisten bewusst ist wir leben heute
immer noch von dem was in der Zeit
stäuber Huber investiert wurde für
Wissenschaft und Forschung davon leben
wir heute
und wir haben jetzt mit der Hightech
Agenda angesetzt mit über dreieinhalb
mittlerweile sind es fast vier
Milliarden Euro die größte
technologieoffensive in der bayerischen
Geschichte gemacht wie investieren für
künstliche Intelligenz mehr als ganze
Länder Italien Spanien es sind beim
Hochtechnologie Computing Supercomputing
mittlerweile an dem technologiegedanken
Giganten Südkorea vorbei und ja ich
stehe auch zu Luft und Raumfahrt auch
wenn manch einer Maul das war bei
Strauss auch so Bavaria One ist ein
Erfolg fast 50 Prozent der ESA Aufträge
gehen ein Deutschland an Bayern und
lieber Markus Blume die Fakultät
explodiert geradezu vorzulauf der
größten Luft und Raumfahrt Fakultät in
Europa und wenn ich an manche sagen
Gefühle will zum Mond ich nicht aber
wenn die Grünen wollen machen wir ein
Quartier auf der Rückseite des Mondes
dann müssen wir sich mehr sehen liebe
Freunde da mache ich mit
vor der Landtagswahl war mein Freund
Hubert auch ein Gegner ich habe ihn
jetzt zur Belohnung zum Raumfahrt
die letzten gelesen das schöne der
glaubt dann Aliens
eigentlich nicht
aber als ich jetzt in Aachen die
FDP-Politikerin Frau Agnes Strack
Zimmermann gesehen habe kam mir schon
Zweifel liebe Freunde kamen mir schon
leichte Zeitung
also
die heilige Agenda ist auch seit ganz
persönlich das Herzstück meiner Zukunft
Agenda es wird uns für die nächsten 20
Jahre Wettbewerbsvorteile bringen
es wird jetzt schon die Großen dieser
Welt Apple Google Microsoft vielleicht
auf Facebook kommen zu uns ich höre
jetzt immer wieder den Zeitungen holt
uns ab
die Wahrheit ist doch nicht dass die
Kiel Rostock Hannover oder Bremen unsere
Gegner sind die Kontrolle mit London
Mumbai la und Shanghai und ich kann
allen nur mal raten die singen zieht den
Bayern die Läden Hosen aus zieht lieber
euch warm an denn die meisten die singen
gehen hinterher nackt nach Hause wir
werden diesen Wettbewerb gewinnen liebe
Freunde da könnt ihr euch noch
einstellen
unsere bayern-bilanz ist top und das
Bayern Gefühl das einzigartig denn wir
bekennen uns und wir betrachten es als
Mutant zu Tradition so Brauchtum zur
Heimat
als wir bei der Beerdigung von Papst
Benedikt waren war tief bewegen liebe
Freunde wir haben viele von euch dabei
danke
da waren Gänsehautmoment als am Ende
dann der Sarg in die Petersdom geführt
wurde gab es spontan Beifall ich durfte
oben bei den Staatsgästen stehen stand
hinter Scholz
und
plötzlich
physikalische Beschreibung ja
und plötzlich gab es Musik
es war nicht gar nicht mehr vorziehen
weil
plötzlich spielt er eine Blaskapelle die
Bayernhymne und von unten und
Petersplatz Drang nach oben die
Bayernhymne ich selber habe dann mit
gesungen Olaf Scholz hat mich wirklich
völlig entsetzt und schlumpfig
angeschaut
ich war total beeindruckt und stolz so
ein Moment den gibt es nur mit Bayern
liebe Freunde nur
und dann lese ich immer wieder
aber Eiern ist international ja nicht
attraktiv
alles ist bei uns
man muss übrigens gar nicht die Welt
fahren wenn man in Bayern ist und bleibt
dann trifft man die Welt die kommt zu
uns G7 Münchener Sicherheitskonferenz
riesen Sache
und da kommen sie macron
Boris Johnson letztes
sympathisch weil der fragt das erste ist
was gibt es zu trinken
jetzt kann mir der Harris am
beeindruckend
Präsident der USA letztes Jahr beim G7
wirklich beeindruckend man kennt viele
Staatsgäste wenn dann so die Air Force
One kommt ja so was besonderes also
Amerikaner kommen übrigens mit fast 1000
Mann sogar eingefallen
beiden kamen runter würde dynamisch
freundlich sagen ich habe mich herzlich
begrüßt dann sah wir haben das beste
Aufgebot was man haben Gebirgsschützen
da fragt er was ist denn das WhatsApp
sagte Varian Army ja
aber das
beeindruckend zwei Tage später
Leben des Entsetzen in Berlin
in den linken Redaktionsstuben also
nein in Berlin sagt man
jetzt entsteht in der Welt der Eindruck
so war die lesartung dass die glauben
die Welt das alle Bayern alle deutschen
so aussehen wie die Bayern
alle deutschen sehen so aus wie Bayern
meine Antwort was für ein Imagegewinn
für Deutschland liebe Freunde was für
ein Imagegewinn ja
wir sind nicht perfekt und wir haben
eine Menge zu tun wir sind eine
überheblich aber da uns keinen andere
lobt müssen wir das manchmal auch selber
tun und ich sag nur eins wir sind das
bessere Deutschland und der alte Satz
gilt einfach ins neueste Bierpreis
Buddies feierte Bayern der gilt auch
heute noch liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
früher hieß es Laptop und Lederhose
manche sagen Leberkäse
Gigabit und Gamsbart
Raumfahrt und Rosenkranz gefällt mir ja
oder Hightech mit Heimat oder Heimat mit
Herz wenn man uns beschreiben müsste uns
Bayern für alle die uns nicht so kennen
dann würde ich sagen wir sind trendy und
traditionell zugleich
wir sind lässig und leistungsstark
zugleich wir sind gemütlich und genial
das ist Bayern und ganz ehrlich ich sehe
überhaupt keinen Grund warum die Bayern
ein schlechtes Gewissen haben sollten
weil sie so sind es kommen viele
Menschen zu uns und alle freuen sich
hier zu sein ich kenne ganz wenige die
bewusst in grüne Länder fahren und darum
lassen wir unseren Lebensstil nicht
verändern und vorschreiben von anderen
liebe Freunde
of life wird fortgesetzt
so das ist
das sachliche Buch ausgebreitet die
ausgangsweise Ausgangslage für die
Landtagswahl im Herbst ich bin
optimistisch das gebe ich zu nicht nur
wir haben ein tolles Team das will ich
ausführlich sagen es ist keine
one-men-show in jedem bayerischen Bezirk
haben wir tolle Persönlichkeit in
Unterfranken unsere digitalministerin
Judith Galla
in Oberfranken unsere Europaministerin
Melanie Hummel
in Mittelfranken mich auch ja aber
unsere sichere Bank und den
innovativsten Kostüm aussuche in
Veitshöchheim Joachim Herrmann
in Schwaben unseren super
Gesundheitsminister Klaus holitschek
in Niederbayern und der Oberpfalz unsere
beiden Ostbayern Bomber auf der einen
Seite den besten Finanzminister in
Deutschland Albert fürg aus der Pfalz
und in Niederbayern Christian banreitner
der deutlich mehr politisches und
tatsächliches Gewicht auf die Waage
bringt als andere Niederbayern
und den Oberbayern unsere wunderbare
Ilse Aigner fünf Minister zwei
Generalsekretäre liebe Freunde nennt ihr
mir mal Politiker anderer Parteien zum
Beispiel der SPD
der Spitzenkandidat der SPD den kennt
kaum einer und die die ihn kennen finden
in unsympathisch liebe Freunde und
Freunde
seine Ko-Vorsitzende sagte letzte in
einem Interview Florian von genau
sei sei einer der nettesten Menschen die
sie kennen war das schließ ich sie hat
einen sehr sehr kleinen bekannten Geist
was ich beim SPD-Vorsitzenden verstehe
liebevollen Freunde
wir haben tolle Leute so viele andere
die noch da sind ich habe jetzt so die
Spitzen nach der jeweiligen listenane
und wir haben auch einen anderen
Regierungsstil liebe Freunde als die
Ampel und zwar verlässlich seriös und
ohne dauerzockt und deswegen ich sage ja
wir setzen die Koalition in München fort
nicht mit den Grünen sondern mit den
Freien Wählern liebe Freunde
ja und das war unsere Übertragung vom
politischen Aschermittwoch in Passau
zunächst erstmal das war die CSU mit dem
Parteivorsitzenden Markus Söder und ich
frage Roman Deininger von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung er ist ja einer der
Experte wenn es um das Thema CSU geht
wenn es um das Thema Markus Söder geht
wir hatten auf sie die Rede von Markus
Söder wohnt anderthalb Stunden dauert
ihr jetzt schon an gewirkt
afd-positionen ich würde sagen Markus
Söder hat heute nichts ausgelassen kein
Ziel und keine Pointe hat sicher auch
die eher billigen mitgenommen aber das
ist ja was die Parteibasis
Aschermittwoch erwartet wir haben eine
Rede gehört die in ihrer guten ersten
Hälfte sich an der Ampel abgearbeitet
hat das alte södermotiv vom Ampel Norden
der dem angeblich frei im Süden um den
Kragen will
die letzten Drittel der redet dann seine
Bilanz in Bayern in den Mittelpunkt
gestellt hat ja den Stolz auf die schöne
Bayernland geschworen und insgesamt war
es eine Rede die effektiv war die
funktioniert hat beim Publikum viel
Applaus und viele einzelne klatschte
stellen aber es war keine Regel die
Überraschungen geworden hätte ich fand
am interessantesten dass er beim Thema
Migration etwas härtere Worte also
wirklich gefunden hat aber jetzt auch
keinerlei Grenze fortgeschritten hat der
ankomme beim Publikum war eigentlich die
Stelle also gemeint hat dass zur
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft auch
deutsche Sprachkenntnisse gehören das
ist ein alter bierzeltklassiker der CSU
und der hat auch heute funktioniert er
hat sich aber ja abgearbeitet vor allen
Dingen und das fand ich ganz interessant
an den Grünen also er hat ja weniger die
SPD und die FDP angegriffen in seiner
Rede sondern vor allen Dingen grünen
Umweltschutz Ziele und die NGOs war das
für Sie überraschen was bezweckt er
damit
die Grünen sind der Hauptgegner von
Markus Schröder in diesem
Landtagswahlkampf Söder ist ein
Politiker der so richtig nur
funktioniert und auch zu rhetorische
Form aufläuft wenn er jemand hat an dem
man sich reiben kann und in diesem
Wahlkampf in Bayern kann das keine
einzelne Person sein es gibt keinen
Gegenkandidaten keine Gegenkandidatin
der oder die mit Söder auf Augenhöhe ist
es sind die Grünen als Partei als
gesellschaftliche Kraft deswegen also
diese überborgende Menge an Witzen über
das Gendern über vegane Ernährung und
viele andere Dinge die angeblich den
bayerischen Bayern von der ampelung von
den Grünen in Bayern übergestimmt werden
sollen danke schön Roman Deininger von
der Süddeutschen Zeitung für diese
Einschätzung
danke Ihnen
ja und möchte es natürlich die Rede von
Markus Söder den csu-partei-chef auch
noch mal hier im Studio besprechen und
wir haben ja auch schon darüber
gesprochen Herr Decker Frank Decker
Politikwissenschaftler von der
Universität in Bonn
wären wir die Rede betrachtet haben er
hat die Grünen vor allen Dingen
angegriffen aber es war auch keine
wirklich staatstragende rede dir da
gehalten hat also so richtig hier
empfohlen für bundespolitische Aufgaben
hat er sich nicht oder sehen Sie das an
anders also staatstragende reden werden
am politischen Aschermittwoch ohne hin
nicht gehalten natürlich auch den
Kontext noch einmal betrachten
es war ja recht überraschend dass es
2021 dann zu einem recht einem Wechsel
kommt in Richtung SPD eigentlich hatte
sich alles darauf eingestellt dass es
eine schwarz-grüne Regierung gibt oder
eine
Jamaika-Koalition und Söder hatte sich
ja selber beworben diese anzuführen und
dass er sich jetzt so an den Grünen
abarbeiten kann
im Bund ja hätte regieren müssen das
liegt eben daran dass man eben jetzt
nicht mit den Grünen regieren muss man
ist im Bund in der Opposition und das
hat es ihm natürlich hier erleichtert
auch die Grünen massiv auch mit
bundespolitischen Themen
anzugreifen und der andere Punkt ist
dass seine Ausgangsposition doch jetzt
in Bayern so gut ist dass er darauf
setzen kann ohne die Grünen regieren zu
können wenn das nicht so wäre dann
müsste er natürlich da auch bisschen
vorsichtiger sein denn eine Partei zu
verteufeln mit der man dann am nächsten
Tag koalieren muss müsste das wird
schwierig und die Grünen sind haben wir
eben auch gehört
der Hauptgegner für die CSU die muss ja
im Grunde an zwei Fronten kämpfen
interessant fand ich bei der Rede das
zwar das Thema Migration angesprochen
wurde aber die AFD als Konkurrent die
AFD ist ja bundespolitisch auch in
Bayern auch im Aufwind also sich
profitiert auch von diesen Krisen Themen
die AFD hat er überhaupt nicht erwähnt
dann haben wir die FDP die ist
allerdings sehr schwach in Bayern und
die Freien Wähler hat er ja im Grunde am
Schluss auch als Wunschkoalitionspartner
bezeichnet also überhaupt keine Rede
mehr von einer Alleinregierung da haben
wir also die Konkurrenz auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite machen
die Grünen der CSU aber auch Konkurrenz
nicht nur in den Großstädten sondern zum
Teil auch im ländlichen Raum also das
Thema Landwirtschaft hat ja auch eine
große Rolle gespielt da gibt es durchaus
auch Landwirte die vielleicht dieser
Idee ökologischer Landwirtschaft
durchaus aufgeschlossen gegenüber stehen
also er hat diesen diese
Auseinandersetzung heute eigentlich nur
an der einen Front geführt nämlich in
Richtung der Grünen es gab eine Ausnahme
da hatte sich an der FDP abgearbeitet
bei dem Thema Erbschaftssteuer und das
ist natürlich ein Thema wo bayerische
Landesinteressen sehr stark tangiert
sind das steht natürlich für ein
CSU-Politiker immer im Vordergrund eben
auch die bayerischen Interessen auch die
bayerischen Interessen im Bund in den
Vordergrund zu stellen da wollte ich
nämlich auch noch mal drauf hinaus auch
noch mal einhaken warum funktioniert das
eigentlich in Bayern so gut mit diesem
Gefühl Bayern first das ist ja wirklich
schon er hat ja gesagt nicht Deutschland
und die USA hat ja von Bayern und den
USA beispielsweise die die bayerische
US-amerikanischen Beziehungen von so
etwas hat er ja gesprochen das würde ja
so kann man sich das zumindest in
anderen Bundesländern doch kaum
vorstellen dass das so funktioniert
würde also das hat ja eine gewisse
Position das beginnt ja schon mit der
Bezeichnung als Freistaat also diese
Betonung auch der
Eigenständigkeit
und das wird ja auch zum Ausdruck
gebracht dass es eine eigenständige
christdemokratische Partei oder
christliche Partei in Bayern gibt das
war schon in der Weimarer Republik so
und im Kaiserreich also das die
Zentrumspartei hieß in Bayern bayerische
Volkspartei und die CSU hat es in einem
ganz besonderen Maße geschafft eben auch
Bayern mit sich selber zu identifizieren
auch dass sie im Bundes lange Zeit
mitregiert hat hat ja in Bayern sehr
stark genutzt und heute ist ja umgekehrt
dann kritisiert worden das kann man aber
wenn man im Bund in der Opposition ist
das Bayern benachteiligt wird durch die
Ampel Regierung und ein Dauer Thema ist
natürlich der Länderfinanzausgleich
deren Reform aber die CSU als sie selber
in der Bundesregierung war in der
letzten
Legislaturperiode selber mitgewirkt hat
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung soweit